hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible q
a I am Jason Bradley and I'm so excited
that you're joining us you know I love
this program it's really like a
customized Bible study and what I mean
by that is you send in your questions
and then we have wonderful students of
the word who answer your questions from
the word of God and I want to share with
you how you can send those questions in
if you haven't done so you may text your
questions to
618-228-3975 again that's
618-228-3975 or you may email your quest
questions to Bible QA at 3abn.tv bible
QA at 3abn.tv and if you're on Instagram
please send us a DM or a direct message
at 3abn underscore official again that's
3abn underscore official I want to
introduce our our wonderful students of
the word we have here Shelly Quinn
Shelly is great to have you it seems a
little strange today just to have me
sitting on this set and then we have
James joining us by Zoom but we're glad
that you're joining us and we're going
to get into some interesting questions
yes absolutely and Pastor Rafferty is so
great to have you we wish you were here
in person in the studio but we're happy
you can join us
good to be here Jason and Shelley
joining you via Zoom
we do have some great questions today
really looking forward to our question
and answer time absolutely absolutely
but before we dive into these questions
until the word of God I'd like for us to
pray Shelley would you pray for us
absolutely
our loving Heavenly Abba Father
we come before you Lord in our hearts
swell with love
and praise for you thank you Lord
for what you've done to save us and what
you continue to do to save us
father we're so very grateful that you
made your word available to us you did
not leave us as orphans you gave us your
word and your spirit and we pray that by
the power of your spirit our answers
today will come directly from your word
and we'll
be satisfying to those who are watching
thank you for our three ABN family who
is watching or listening to this program
bless them bless this program father for
the glory of your name in Christ we pray
amen amen amen now this is interesting
as you mentioned we have only two people
uh this time so you'll each have four
minutes per question but you'll get one
question that you can take five minutes
to answer uh Pastor Rafferty will come
to you first if the woman in Revelation
chapter 12 verse 1 is the church and the
twelve stars are the apostles how were
they created before Jesus was born in
Revelation chapter 12 verse 2.
all right great question a couple
answers here just for that question
number one Revelation was not really
written in order of events but in a
general progression Revelation like
Daniel has these prophetic Cycles Daniel
has four Daniel two seven eight and
eleven Revelation also has four
Revelations churches seals trumpets and
plagues and each one of those Cycles
enlarges it repeats and enlarges but
that being said we know that the woman
in Bible prophecy represents a church
and we find that in Ephesians chapter 5
for example where we're told
that a man shall leave his father and
mother verse 31 shall be joined unto his
wife and they too shall be one flesh
this is a great mystery verse 32 but I
speak concerning Christ and the church
and then in Jeremiah 6 2 I have likened
the daughter of Zion to a calmly and
delicate woman so yes we have a woman
symbolizing a church and the question
was if Revelation 12 1 is the church and
the 12 stars of the Apostles how were
they created before Jesus was born well
we know that the church was in place
before Christ was born but not the
Christian church it was the Jewish
church so this woman as she's pictured
here in Revelation 12 verse 1 is the
Jewish church that is the church that
was on in place before the Christian
church and we know this because Jesus
was born a Jew
verse 5 of Revelation chapter 12 tells
us that after Jesus was born of the
woman which represents the Jewish church
that Jesus was caught up to heaven and
what happened to God's church after that
well it transitioned from the Jewish
Church to the Christian church that fled
Into the Wilderness and we see that
depicted in Revelation chapter 12 verse
6. so we see here that this woman
represents the church but it is the
Jewish Church from which Christ is born
the question asked if Revelation 12 1 is
the church and the 12 stars are the
apostles well those 12 stars are not
exactly the apostles what we find is
that 12 represents God's kingdom number
and God has two sets of 12 in the Book
of Revelation the first set of 12 is the
Old Testament tribes the 12 tribes of
Israel and we see them as a vital part
of God's church if you fast forward to
Revelation 21
you're going to find the description of
the New Jerusalem City and there are 12
gates and those 12 gates have the name
of one of the 12 tribes on top of it now
there are 12 foundations also and those
12 foundations are named after the 12
apostles so to say that the 12 stars are
so the apostles would be to leave out
the bigger picture that Revelation gives
to us which is inclusive of the 12
tribes I would say those 12 stars are
simply representing God's kingdom number
12 God's kingdom number Stars we're told
represent God's people now we read about
that in Revelation chapter 12 or excuse
me Daniel chapter 12 verse 3 where it
says that they that be wise shall shine
is the brightness of the firmament and
they that turn many to righteousness as
the Stars forever and ever so God's
people
are represented by the Stars 12 is God's
kingdom number and it's inclusive of the
12 tribes and or the 12 apostles and the
woman is the Church of God which is
inclusive of the Old Testament Church
the Jewish Church from which Christ was
born and the New Testament Church the
Christian church that flees Into the
Wilderness in Revelation chapter 12 and
verse 6. and just one last thought
we know that Revelation 12 is not
written in order because in verses 7
through 9 we have a reflection back to
the great apostasy that began in heaven
the war with Michael and Satan and Satan
being cast out of heaven so we have to
look at Revelation as a progressive but
not necessarily uh book written in
perfect order amen amen thank you for
that explanation you know anytime you
get a question about Daniel or
Revelation I have flashbacks to
Salvation and symbols and signs but if
they're they're good memories they're
good memories so thank you for that
Shelly can you please interpret Genesis
chapter 6 verses 1 through 4. was it
fallen angels and humans having
relations
oh that's an interesting question and
I'll tell you why it comes up is because
ancient Jewish commentators made it
thought that the sons of God were Angels
but we know that in Matthew 22 Jesus
said that Angels do not marry so that's
in Matthew 22 30. let's look and that
that kind of makes them asexual they're
not sexual beings but let's look at
Genesis 6 1-4 we're going to look in
context always read in context sometimes
we we see something and it catches our
attention and we're going oh what does
that mean read before and after and find
out Genesis 6 verses 1 through 4. now it
came to pass
when men who are we talking about men
began to multiply on the face of the
Earth
and daughters were born to whom to them
to the men
that the sons of God saw the daughters
of men that they were beautiful
and they took wives for themselves of
all whom they chose and the Lord said
now we're going to bring this back in
again we're talking about God's talking
about Humanity my spirit shall not
strive with man forever for he is in
deep flesh at his days shall be
120 years
and then verse 4 says there were giants
on the earth in those days and also
afterward when the sons of God
came in to the daughters of men and they
bore children to them those were the
Mighty Men Who were of old men of renown
sons of God is a covenant title that is
used in the Old and New Testaments
any human being that was in Covenant
relationship with God is referred to as
Son of God we see in Luke 3 in verse 38
Adam is called the Son of God Exodus
chapter 4 verses 22 and 23 this is
Exodus 4 22 and 23 God is speaking to
Moses
and he says then you shall say to
Pharaoh thus says the Lord
Israel is my son
my firstborn so I say to you let my son
go that he may serve me but if you
refuse to let him go indeed I will kill
your son your first burn born the oldest
and Deuteronomy 14 Moses is speaking to
the second generation of the Israelites
at the edge of promise and he says you
are the children of the Lord your God
well what is John 1 12 tell us
John in the New Testament chapter 1 and
verse 12 says as many as receive Christ
he gives the right to become children of
God to those who believe in his name
Jesus said as one of the Beatitudes in
Matthew 5
and verse 9 blessed are the peacemakers
for they shall be called the sons of God
now what happened Adam his son Cain
killed righteous Abel
God sent Cain away and Cain was a
Wandering Vagabond so then Seth was born
to Adam and Eve Seth was a righteous man
and after Seth had his son men began to
call on the name of the Lord so the
descendants of Godly Seth who were in
Covenant relationship with God With God
would be called the sons of God the
daughters of men would be the
descendants of Cain they were pagans the
daughters were beautiful just not
virtuous so
this resulted in a total Corruption of
humanity and that's the point of the
whole passage is the wickedness that was
widespread on the earth and the Lord had
to send the flood amen thank you Shelly
that's the question that comes up quite
a bit uh Pastor Rafferty this will be
your five-minute question who are the
two witnesses in Revelation this comes
from Robert out of Colorado
okay Robert out of Colorado let's just
look at the scriptures here Revelation
11 verse 3 and I will give power unto my
two witnesses and they shall prophecy a
thousand two hundred and three score
days clothed in sackcloth these are the
two olive trees and the two candlesticks
stand before the Lord the god of the
earth so the two witnesses are
identified in Revelation chapter 11
verse 4 as being two olive trees and two
candlesticks then it goes on to say in
verse five If any man will hurt them
fire proceeds out of their mouth and
devours their enemies and if any man
will hurt them he must be in this man to
be killed these have power to shut
Heaven that it rained not in the days of
their prophecy and they have power over
Waters to turn in the blood and to Smite
the Earth with all plagues as often as
they will so the two witnesses have
power to Smite the Earth with plagues
the two witnesses are the two olive
trees the two witnesses have power to
hurt men with fire that proceeds out of
their mouth verse 7 and they shall when
they shall finish their testimony the
Beast citizens out of the bottomless pit
shall make war against them and shall
overcome them and kill them so the two
witnesses are attacked by a beast that
ascends out of the bottomless pit
and this Beast kills them and their dead
dead bodies lie in the street that is
the great of the great city which is
spiritually called Sodom and Egypt where
also our Lord was crucified and they
have the people and of the kindreds and
tongues and Nations shall see their dead
bodies three and a half days and shall
not suffer their dead bodies be putting
Graves this is talking in symbolic
language of course and they that dwell
upon the Earth shall rejoice over them
and make Mary and send gifts one to
another because these two prophets
tormented them and that dwelt on the
Earth but after three and a half days
verse 11 the spirit of God entered into
them and they stood upon their feet and
a great fear Came Upon them which saw
them so there's a Revival that takes
place in Revival of life that takes
place with these two witnesses after
three and a half days and then that same
hour it says
um they hear a voice from Heaven saying
come up hither and they ascend to heaven
in a cloud and their enemies beheld them
and then there was a great earthquake
the tenth part of the city fell and
seven thousand were slaves so let's just
go back now to break this down the two
olive trees are candlesticks are
identified the ones that identify the
two witnesses verse four are identified
in Zechariah Chapter 4 verses one
through six and God tells us there
that the vision of the candlesticks uh
and the bowls and the Seven lamps and
the Seven pipes to the lamps these two
olive trees verse three of Zechariah
Chapter Four
um one on the right side and one on the
left side of the bowl the this vision of
this candlesticks and these olive trees
represent the word of God then he said
unto me this is the word of the Lord
adorable saying not by might nor by
power but by my spirit says the Lord of
hosts so these two witnesses according
to the Bible represent the word of God
the Old Testament and the New Testament
uh we know this because in second Peter
1 21 we're told the prophecy came not an
old time but the will of man but holy
men of God spake as they were moved by
the Holy Ghost so there you have the
spirit not by might nor by power but by
my spirit says the Lord of hosts the
spirit inspires the word of God the word
of God Old Testament and New Testament
is being spoken of here it's the light
that comes from the holy oil and that
light comes upon men and speaks to them
and if men
uh speak now some people believe that
these two witnesses are Moses and Elijah
because of the plague mentioned uh
mentioned there the plagues mentioned
there but the water and the other
plagues like Moses and Elijah brought
upon the Earth but if you look at Exodus
5 1 and 1st Kings 17 and 18 you'll find
that Moses and Elijah both spoke the
word of God they spoke by the word of
God it wasn't really them that spoke but
it was God speaking through them so
again we're directed to the word of God
and then when you look in Revelation
chapter 22 18 and 19 verses 5 and 6 are
telling us in Revelation 11 that they uh
have powers might win men with plagues
in revelation 22 18-19 when we change
the word of God we receive the plagues
of this book so again that directs us to
the word of God and then verse 7 talks
about the 42 months
well actually versus uh two and three
talk about 42 months and 1260 days and
we know in verse 7 there was an
atheistic power that arose out of this
pit this this this Beast is atheism it
made war against the Bible and attacked
the Bible and the Bible lay dead it was
outlawed and it lay dead as it were in
the streets of atheist France and that
that prophecy lasted three and a half
prophetic days or three and a half years
from November of 1793 to June of 1797
and then in verses 8 through 12 we see
the Bible exalted as a result of the
horrors of the French Revolution with
the British Bible society in 1804 and
the American Bible society in 1816. so
quickly to summarize these two witnesses
represent the old and the New Testament
the Old and New Testament were were
preached and shared during the 1260
years of uh papal supremacy of the dark
cages in the guise of sackcloth in other
words there was a lot of persecution
against them they spake God's word they
brought light to the world but there was
a lot of opposition to them specifically
during the French Revolution the Bible
was burned in the streets lay dead there
so to speak and figure it figurative
language but then the Bible had a
resurrection because after the three and
a half years all of Europe saw saw how
terrible it was to ban the Bible and
Bible societies were raised up and the
word of God was as it were resurrected
and exalted to the heavens so the two
witnesses the word of God amen amen
thank you for that thorough answer there
and uh Shelley we're going to come to
you on this one here I believe that once
a person dies he or she rests in the
grave until the second coming can you
please help me understand Ecclesiastes
chapter 3 verse 21. this comes from
Vernon ah Vernon good question and let
us
context remember how
important context so if you have your
Bibles open to Ecclesiastes 3 we'll look
at verse 19 first
and what Solomon writes for what happens
to the sons of men also happens to
animals one thing befalls them as one
dies so dies the other
surely they all have one breath the word
in the Hebrew there is ruach breath and
spirit mean the same thing man has no
advantage over animals for all his
vanity I'll go to one place all are from
the dust and I'll return to the dust who
knows the spirit the ruach that's the
same word as breath in verse 19 of the
sons of men which goes upward and the
spirit of the animal which goes down to
the Earth so both man and beasts have
ruach it's it's the life principle the
breath of life that God has breathed
into us I want to read to you a couple
of different translations of that verse
because you will see how it plays out a
little better in the Hebrew Ecclesiastes
3 21 in the end simplified reads who
knows the spirit of man whether it goes
upward and the spirit of the Beast
whether it goes downward to the Earth
now let's look at
Ecclesiastes 3 21 in the RSV revised
Standard Version it says who knows
whether the spirit of man goes upward
and the spirit of the Beast go down to
the Earth and again in The New American
Standard Bible Ecclesiastes 319 says the
fate of the sons of men the fate of the
Beast is the same one dies so does the
other indeed they all have the same
breath that ruach and there is no
Advantage for man over Beasts for all
his vanity all go to the same place all
came from the dust all returned to the
Dust
who knows that the breath of man ascends
upward into the breath of the Beast
descends downward to the to the Earth so
basically what Solomon is saying is hey
it is apparent knowledge that man and
beast when you die dust you are dust you
return that's obvious but he's he's
basically saying what happens to the
life principle that breath of life that
God has put in man who knows if it Go
the man if the Breath of Life returns to
God if it goes upward or who knows if
the one of the beasts goes to the earth
now he does come in chapter 12 and verse
7 of Ecclesiastes and he does say that
the dust will return to the Earth as it
was and the spirit will return to God
who gave it but Vernon you are right
when we die we rest in the grave Solomon
is just making a philosophy difficult
question here yes yes thank you thank
you for that explanation you know the
state of the Dead is something that
comes oh absolutely right a bit and
anytime we don't read hear a little
there a little you know that's when
things get a little confusing uh so
thank you for shedding some light on
that perhaps you're sitting at home and
you're saying you know I have a question
that I really want answered you may text
your questions to
618-228-3975 again that's
618-228-3975 or you can email us at
bibleqa at
3abn.tv again that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
or if you're on Instagram please send us
a DM at 3abn underscore official again
that's 3abn underscore official Pastor
Rafferty we come to you with this one
Revelation indicates that the 144 000
will be the only remaining people alive
to see the second coming of Christ does
this mean that there will only be 144
000 saved Christians alive at the second
coming this comes from Steve out of
Virginia
foreign
that's a great question of course
Revelation is a symbolic book and when
we talk about the number the 144 000 it
can be controversial but the 144 000
could be taken literally as you're
taking it or it can be taken
symbolically so all we need to do is we
need to look in the context of the
scripture to see if we can figure out
whether it's literal or symbolic
thankfully there are only two places in
Revelation where the number is used
specifically so we don't have a lot of
searching to do there's nowhere else in
the Bible with this Revelation it's
implied in chapter 15 but it's used in
chapter 7 and 14. looking at Chapter 14
verse 1 I looked and lo and lamb stood
on Mount Zion and with him 144 000
having his father's name written in
their foreheads you already start out
this verse with symbolism the lamb is
symbolic of Christ and of course the 144
000 have their father's name written in
their foreheads that's not literal
either that's talking about having the
character of God in our foreheads and I
Heard a Voice verse 2 from Heaven as a
voice of many Waters as the voice of
great Thunder and I heard the voice of
Harper's Harpy with their Harps and they
sung as it were a new song Before the
Throne before the four beasts and the
elders there's a symbolism again with
the four beasts and no man could learn
that song but the 144 000 who were
redeemed from the earth these are they
which are not defiled with women
now this again is symbolism they're not
to follow women for they are virgins
these are they which follow the Lamb
with us wherever he goes they are
redeemed from among them being the first
fruits under God into the lamb this
verse is filled with symbolism you're
going to take it literally you're going
to have to say that the 144 000 are
literally Jewish male virgins who have
never literally slept with a woman and
follow the lamb wherever he goes but we
understand symbolism here to be the
meaning the woman representing God's
church and the 144 000 being a symbolic
number of God's redeemed people now it's
interesting when you go to Revelation
chapter
and of course first fruits being the
chief roots or the first the best of the
Harvest now when you go to Revelation
chapter 7 you're going to find here the
144 000 are described as the sealed of
the 12 tribes of Israel Revelation
chapter 7 verses 4 through 8. I heard
the number of them that were sealed and
they were sealed 144 000 of all the
tribes of the children of Israel if we
take that literally that means only the
literal tribes of the children of Israel
are going to be sealed with the Seal of
God or as you said saved but we don't
understand this literally and there's
several reasons why number one is when
you look at the 12 tribes here the
literal tribes of Israel were scattered
abroad ten of them were lost so to speak
and so you have an impossibility here
for Redemption if only the literal Trail
tribes of Israel are going to be sealed
because they are no longer available to
us and then you have have a tribe that's
missing the tribe of Dan one of the
original isn't here the tribe of
Manasseh one of Joseph's son has
replaced him which gives us some
spiritual meaning uh so what is God
actually saying here in Revelation
chapter 7 concerning the ceiling we know
that all those who are faithful to God
and refuse the mark of the beast will be
sealed with the Seal of God
12 is God's kingdom number we mentioned
that earlier in an earlier question and
a thousand is the largest number in the
Bible when God wants to get big he uses
the number Thousand Times Ten thousands
and thousands of thousands but he never
uses a million or a billion or a
trillion not in the original Greek
language so twelve one thousands of of
the tribe of Judah twelve one thousands
of the tribe of Ruben twelve one
thousands of the tribe of Levi God is
saying the kingdom number times a
thousand twelve times 12 times 12 is
144. a thousand is the largest number
God is trying to impress us Upon Our
Minds there's going to be a lot of
people saved in the kingdom of God and
if we miss it in the first eight verses
of Revelation seven he brings it home to
us in the ninth verse where John doesn't
hear but he actually sees a great
multitude that no man can number saved
in the Kingdom of Heaven so to answer
your question directly no there are not
going to be only 144 and literal people
saved when Jesus comes there's going to
be a great multitude that no one can
number in heaven and all of that great
multitude we're going to see millions of
people saved in the end time standing
firm for God with the Seal of God
following Jesus wherever he goes amen
amen you know that brings so much hope
amen that brings so much hope and
context is key Shelley this is your five
minute question Deuteronomy chapter 14
verses 22 through 27 seems to read as if
God is giving permission to drink wine
and strong drink and or whatever our eye
lusts after one Pastor explained it as
if God winked at their ignorance this
makes no sense to me this is from Julie
from Texas
Julie this is a great question God's
nature of unselfish love God's character
of righteousness righteousness never
changed Malachi 3 6 he says I am the
Lord I changed not
Hebrews 13 8 says Jesus is the same
yesterday today and forever we know that
God's plan of righteousness by faith has
his Covenant his Everlasting Covenant
was introduced in the garden and it has
never changed it has always been the
lamb who was slain from the foundation
of the world but I will say that we
can't expect that the way God dealt with
everyone to have never changed because
God is so good at meeting us where we
are and then leading us a little further
he doesn't he doesn't unload everything
on us all at once I'll put it that way
let's look at this because again
we are talking context you can't say oh
God just let them lust after what they
wanted and have this this Feast that was
an orgy no no no
Deuteronomy 14
22-27 first of all verse 22 it is
speaking of the second tithe not the
levitical type but the tithe that not to
support the church but to support
families God asked the people spend ten
percent on yourself come Rejoice before
me in my presence he is calling them to
these feast days and this the title was
used to purchase Delicacies to be
consumed in a holy Feast before the Lord
let's look verse 23 you shall eat before
the Lord your God in the place where he
chooses to make his name abide that
would be the sanctuary so they're eating
a portion of this Fellowship in
fellowship with the Lord this isn't
something that is uh orgy verse 24-25 is
talking about those who had a long
journey instead of having to carry the
tithe of the Grain and their new wine
and their oil or leave their sheep and
cattle along the way they can sell that
for money and then when they arrived at
the temple then they could purchase
whatever their hearts desired let's look
at that in verse 26 of Deuteronomy 14 26
you shall spend that money for whatever
for your heart desires this is New King
James now O King James says uh whatever
your heart lusteth after but the word in
the Hebrew is not talking about a sexual
or evil lusting it is talking about
appetite whatever you want whatever
you're you uh you know we all say oh I'm
craving some mashed potatoes you know
it's whatever they were craving and it
goes on in the new King James it's
saying whatever your heart desires
whether it's oxen or sheep do you want
to have a steak or a lamb and for wine
or similar drink now wine was on it was
grape juice that was mixed with water
and spices it's interesting King James
doesn't say strong drink wine or similar
drink for whatever your heart desires
you shall eat there before the Lord your
God you shall rejoice you and your
household you shall not forsake the
levite who is within your gates for he
is no part and you're inherit in The
Inheritance so you know this is
something that was a holy feast and we
know that the Old Testament and the new
are clear God says in Proverbs 20 verse
1 Wine's a mock or strong drinks a
brawler whoever is Led astray by it's
not wise Isaiah 28 verse 7. you say
they've aired in their way the priests
and the prophets they are envisioned
they stumble in judgment why because
they're drinking and they were counseled
not to drink those priests so here's the
point the evils of wine and strong drink
are clearly pointed out throughout the
Old Testament that we should refrain
from them and boy they're really clear
in the New Testament First Corinthians
10 31 Paul says whatever you eat or
drink do it to the glory of the Lord and
he tells us in First Corinthians 3 16
and 17. not to take anything in our
bodies that would defy fail the temple
of God and so we just have to remember
that there's no excuse for the argument
that God winked at their ignorance in
the past we just have to know that God
tells us that drunkards will not inherit
the kingdom of God in First Corinthians
6 10. so let's just
don't worry oh how can I say this every
scripture is so important but don't let
a single scripture cast your vision of
who the Lord is amen great answer and I
think it's safe to say you got us all
craving mashed potatoes
[Laughter]
Mr Rafferty who is the wicked one that
is referred to in second Thessalonians
chapter 2 verses 4 through 9. this comes
from Marie out of Trinidad
great question Marie out of Trinidad
thank you for that question let's look
at this in the context the first three
verses Paul is speaking to the
Thessalonians it's his second letter to
Thessalonians and the reason he's
writing the second letter is because
they misunderstood his first one when he
wrote to them he talked about the coming
of the Lord he said there's going to be
some who are asleep dead in Christ and
some who are of us are going to be alive
and they thought oh some of us are going
to be alive when Jesus comes so he says
in this second letter no no don't be
Shoon shaken no trouble by Spirit or by
word or even by letter s from us as
though the day of Christ is at hand it's
not going to come for a while first
there's going to be a falling away and
then that son of man or Son of Perdition
the man of sin is going to be revealed
that's second Thessalonians chapter 2 3.
so this gives us a clue as to who this
wicked one is he's the son of perdition
that comes out of the falling away that
word in the Greek is the apostasy
apostasia and then it says in verse 4 he
opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God or his worship so
that he is God sits in the temple of God
showing himself that he is God so here's
another identifying Mark he actually
claims to be God on Earth comes out of
apostasy is the Son of Perdition claims
to be God on Earth
and then as you continue on here it says
there's a power that's withholding verse
6 that he might be revealed in his time
so Paul is telling us this is a future
event to his time when this mystery of
iniquity who's already at work verse 7
will be uh revealed that he that now
will holds him back is going to be taken
out of the way and we might say that was
Pagan of Rome the Pagan power that was
persecuted in the Christian church was
in place in Paul's time once that Pagan
power was taken out of the way another
power is going to be revealed who was
identified as a Christian power but came
out of the apostasy or falling away or
compromise that the early Christian
Church did with Pagan Rome and that
within one is going to be revealed who
verse 8 says the Lord shall consume with
the spirit of his mouth and shall
destroy the brightness of his coming so
this power that was developing in Paul's
day was going to continue to the second
coming of Jesus Christ so these are all
our indicators right
or we know he's the son of perdition in
John chapter 17 verse 12. Judas is
called the son of petition the only
other place it's used so this is a
professed Christian power Judas was a
professed follower or Apostle disciple
of Jesus Christ so this is going to be a
power that professes to follow Jesus and
then we find in verse 12 excuse me in
verse 4 he exalts himself to the place
of God on Earth so again this is a power
that claims to be God on Earth Paul
talks in Acts 20 27-30 that this power
would already was already at work in his
day and his here's how it would come
apart about verse 30 of Acts 20. also of
your own self shall men arise speaking
reverse things to draw away disciples
after them so this would be a power that
would draw away disciples after them
instead of drawing disciples to Christ
and again in first John chapter 2 18-19
John talks about the Antichrist power
the same power that's identified in
second Thessalonians and he says that
this power go is a power that goes out
from us verse 19. they were not out of
us if they didn't of us they would have
continued with us but they went out from
us so again John is simply affirming
what Paul says this wickedness this
lawlessness this apostate power this
Antichrist power started in the
Christian church and it came out of the
Christian Church exalting itself above
Christ putting itself in the place of
Christ in fact John talks about the
octopus in second or third John 9 and 10
who was one who loved to have
preeminence among them and wouldn't even
receive John the disciple of Christ so
basically this power is established in
John's day continues to the second
coming of Christ is an apostate
Christianity with a false worship
self-exalting deceptive it's a power
that is further revealed in Revelation
13 and Daniel 7 as the papacy or papal
Rome home a professed Apostle of Christ
like Judas claims the apostolic
succession from Peter exalts herself in
the place of God claims the power to
forgive sins claims the prerogatives of
God on Earth and is practicing and
prospering to this day so simple answer
to your question who is the power the
wicked one that's referred to in second
Thessalonians 2 4-9 it is papal Rome all
the characteristics fit this apostate
Christian power that has continued to
our day to put itself in the place of
God change God's law and seek to take on
the prerogatives of God in Christ's
Place amen thank you Pastor Rafferty
we're just going to kind of rapid fire
this one now Shelley based on Luke
chapter 16 verses 19 through 31 when
Lazarus died he went to Paradise but
when the rich man died he went to hell
does that mean that the righteous dead
go to heaven or Paradise
um I'm going to say Lynn that when we
die the Bible clearly teaches we sleep
in First Corinthians 15 that we come up
to put on immortality at the last
trumpet Jesus John 5 28 and 29 he says
all who are in their graves will hear
his voice and come forward so here's the
point Ecclesiastes 9 10 says there's no
work or to buy certain knowledge or
wisdom in the grave where you're going
when you read Luke 16
19-31 about the certain rich man and the
poor man named Lazarus this is a parable
and Jesus is obviously using the
language of a parable he says there was
a certain rich man and a certain beggar
named Lazarus he's not referring to Mary
and Martha's brother here but in other
Parables like in Luke 15 11 the parable
of the prodigal son a certain man had
two sons Luke 16 1 the parable of the
unjust Steward there was a certain rich
man who had a steward so what what the
point in the same chapter in Luke 16 13
and 14 Jesus told the Pharisees you
cannot serve with God and Mammon the
Pharisees were lovers of money and they
heard his saying and they scoffed at him
now they believed that riches were a
blessing of God and guess what the
Jewish people had a parable about the
bosom they they referred to Abraham's
bosom as Paradise being you know being
by Abraham's side
they had this parable about the rich man
going to the bosom and the poor man
going to hell to the Grave
so Jesus is merely reversing their
Parable telling the parable of the rich
man and the poor man named Lazarus so
the bottom line is this is a parable
there isn't someone who is sitting
having a beggar that is in heaven and
reclining next to Abraham and a rich man
in Hell saying oh touch my tongue with
water you know Jesus is not teaching
about where we go when we die it's
clearly taught look at John 11 11. he
clearly taught death is a sleep
so what Jesus is teaching them here is
summarized in verses 30 and 31 of Luke
16. he said no father and he said no
Father Abraham if one goes to them from
the dead they will repent
but he said to them if they do not hear
Moses and the prophets neither will they
be persuaded the one rise from the dead
so it's the scripture that has the power
to save our souls and you know what's
ironic Jesus later actually resurrected
Martha and Mary's brother Lazarus after
he had been dead for four days and what
was the reaction of the Jews they wanted
to murder Lazarus and Jesus thank you
Shelley context is key context is key
Pastor Rafferty can you explain how we
add the one day to the 2300 day prophecy
to make it 27 and is God pleased with
this he says we shouldn't add or take
away this is from Matt
hey Matt that's a great statement uh
question uh absolutely no days can be
added or taken away from the 2300
prophetic day prophecy and God is not
pleased with any attempt to do that so
I'm I'm perhaps reading into the
question here and thinking that you're
talking about 27 A.D and how we get to
27 A.D the 27 A.D date is the date of
Christ's anointing as Christ or Messiah
with the Holy Spirit and the 70-week
prophecy which is the first half of the
2300 day prophecy is where we get this
2780 date because it predicts the coming
of Jesus Christ after 483 prophetic days
or 483 literal years from the beginning
of the prophetic cycle so the 70 weeks
can be computed from the New Testament
backwards as well as from the Old
Testament forward and either way we
count the prophetic days we land on the
same year 27 A.D that was the year that
Jesus was anointed with the Holy Spirit
we read about that anointing in Acts
chapter 10 verses 37 and 38 where it
says the word I say to you that you know
which was published throughout all Judea
began From Galilee after the baptism
which John preached how that God
anointed Jesus of Nazareth with the Holy
Ghost and with power who went about
doing good and healing all that were
oppressed of the devil for God was with
him the word anointed here is the same
word for messiah in the Old Testament
and Christ in the New Testament and
that's why he says Jesus of Nazareth not
Jesus Christ because it would be
redundant to say Jesus Christ when he's
talking about him being Anointed with
the holy spirit so acts 10 37 and 38 is
where Luke identifies Christ being
anointed or Jesus being anointed in
coming to Christ
in that context in Luke 3 21 and 22 we
have an actual account of the anointing
of Christ now all the people were
baptized it came to pass that Jesus also
being baptized and praying the heaven
was opened verse 22 and the Holy Ghost
descended in a bodily shape like a dove
upon him and a voice Came From Heaven
which said Thou Art my beloved Son in
thee I am well pleased now we turn to
Luke 3 verse 1 same chapter but verse 1.
this chapter tells us when Jesus was
anointed with the Holy Spirit and
baptized now in the 15th year of type of
the reign of Tiberius Caesar so it's the
15th year of the reign of Tiberius
Caesar we have several historical
documents I've got at least five of them
that tell us that the 15th year of
Tiberius Caesar was A.D 27 27 A.D if you
start from that date and you calculate
backwards 483 prophetic days or literal
years you will go back to 457 BC now
here's where your question gets uh Civic
when you go backwards from 27 A.D you're
going to come to the year 1ad and when
you get to the year 1ad you're going to
jump from 1 A.D to one BC because there
is no zero year and that's where it
seems like we're adding an additional
year in there because we're jumping if
we're going forward from BC One BC to
180 or going backwards from 180 to 1 BC
without a zero year
that's really not an issue at all that
is just the way history has calculated
the years if they added a zero year we'd
end up in 28 A.D but you can't add the
zero year to history because it's not
there so you have to calculate in how
history operates because that's the way
God spoke in prophetic language and
prophetic declarations prophetic members
he understood there was no zero year
when he gave us the 70-week prophecy and
the 483 prophetic days or literal years
leading down to the anointing of Christ
with the holy spirit so you go backwards
you go forward you leave out the zero
year you're not at any year you're not
taking away a year you're simply
calculating history the way it's
documented and the prophecy fits exactly
according to the Bible amen amen thank
you for for sharing that Shelly I was
wondering how the good news about Jesus
spread among the Gentiles Before the
Flood the Bible speaks of Noah as a
preacher but were there other
evangelists before him this is from D oh
D I love this question you know what I
really never thought about it in that
vein but here's the point as soon as
Adam and Eve sinned what did God do he
made he killed the Little Lamb made them
skins that covered their nakedness he
opened the substitutionary sacrificial
system or initiated that and opened the
pathway to righteousness by faith now
after Abel died we have of course the
Bible calls Abel a righteous man he was
made righteous by faith Seth is born to
Adam and Eve Seth is a wonderful man he
says in Genesis 4 26 after Seth was born
that his son to a son was born to Seth
named enosh men began to call on the
name of the Lord righteous Enoch lived
so closely to the Lord that God took him
and translated him to heaven without
dying it says Genesis 5 25 Enoch walked
with God he was not God took him and
even the New Testament says by faith if
this is Hebrews 11 5 by faith Enoch was
taken away so that he did not see death
he was not found because this is the
testimony that he pleased God so the
Bible doesn't specifically say that
Noah's predecessors
evangelized but you can absolutely count
on their lives were a
witness to all they they evangelized
every time they built an ulcer every
time they sacrificed they were telling
the story of righteousness by faith
through the coming Messiah now Noah
sacrificed to God and the Bible says in
Hebrews 11 7 that he became an heir of
righteousness according to Faith second
Peter 2 5 does say that God spared not
the ancient world but preserved Noah a
preacher of righteousness with seven
other persons when he was when he
brought a flood upon the world so did
God have others who were evangelizing
you bet their lives were witnessing and
I guarantee you if men began calling on
the name of the Lord after
Seth's son was born they were talking
about God just like you and I do and our
lives are a letter written on the heart
amen amen thank you Shelley you know we
aren't just about out of time but we
still have two minutes left we're going
to take a brief break we'll be right
back we want to show you how you can
send your questions in to be answered at
a later time so we'll take that break
don't go anywhere we'll be back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
I hope you wrote down how you can send
your questions in at this point I just
want to open up the floor for any final
thoughts that you may have Pastor
Rafferty will start with you
yeah I just really appreciate that the
questions that come in sometimes people
are reading the Bible and they come
across something they say hey that
doesn't look consistent with the rest of
scripture I need to ask a question about
that and of course we too are challenged
as we read the Bible we have some of
these verses that can be difficult for
us to understand and many times what we
have to do is just go with the weight of
evidence so as as we look at these
questions uh we're with you you viewers
as you're sending in your questions and
seeking to understand them better and of
course we want to look at at the
consistency of scripture the weight of
evidence and how God is teaching us and
instructing us I think reaching us where
we are and then moving us up to that
Higher Ground amen and I think that I'm
so glad you said that because we need to
remember the
Simplicity of God's Plan of Salvation
and that is Jesus Christ Revelation 13 8
is the lamb slain from the foundation of
the the world Hebrews 13 20 his blood is
the blood of the Everlasting Covenant
the goal of the Everlasting Covenant he
made him who knew no sin to be sin that
we might become the righteousness of God
God sent his son to die for us that he
could save us and he loves you so much
so is are these questions important and
fun to research yes but don't miss
salvation issues when you get into get
worried about little nuances just hold
on to the Lord hold on to his love walk
in obedience to his command
by his power amen thank you both so much
for answering these wonderful questions
we want to thank you for joining us and
sending in your questions until next
time God bless you
[Music]
thank you